I get FOMO so I'm like I don't want to
miss out on this like with my kids
Kourtney Kardashian on why she's okay
vacationing with her ex Scott Disick and
his new girlfriend Sophia Richie wait oh
my god
what do you see Scott what he just
posted what did he focus what more could
a guy ask for Three's Company and it's
him Kourtney and Sophia in Mexico to be
honest it's a little confusing
she's like easy to be around she's not
like causing drama right I'm really
freaking out on Monday night's episode
of Keeping Up the family it was up in
arms over Kourtney's relationship with
Scott when he posted this pic to
Instagram that had everybody talking as
the trio vacationed together in Mexico
ahead of the holidays last year and
she's gonna be the one deciding way too
late that she is in love with Scott and
wants to spend the rest of her life with
Scott do you know what the she wants
exactly somebody is gonna end up getting
really hurt in this scenario it's never
a dull moment
Kourt described that the issue hit close
to home for her I know with my parents
as soon as everyone got along like life
was so much easier I felt like everybody
was happy so I think as long as you know
we're all okay with it I think it's
really amazing to be able to travel
together on Saturday Sophia and quartz a
little sister Kylie Jenner were slammed
for dressing up in Handmaid's Tale
costumes to celebrate her besties at
stassi's 22nd birthday
social media went wild over Kylie
glamourizing the show which highlights
serious issues like women's rights
violations blessed be the fruit although
Kylie and Sophia appeared to have a
blast regardless of fan feedback
[Music]